[Music]
these days a lot of people very
concerned about making their homes safe
and secure from burglars and trespassers
all right well one of the really big
players in the home security industry
has just come up with a new service that
they would like to introduce for the
first time right here on our show this
is exciting here's their commercial for
this brand new and innovative security
system
okay hold done it's okay if i use your
bedroom to wash my hand
to wash your hands
yes
sure
good
[Music]
ah
hello this is kevin from adt is
everything okay no no someone just tried
to use my toilet ma'am i've alerted the
authorities and help is on its way now
adt home security can help protect your
most valuable asset the family bowl
introducing adt toilet security
what type of monster is defiling your
toilet
thanks to our three-tiered protection
system
tier one
bowl mounted entry sensors will send a
warning signal indicating a possible
breach tier 2 like fingerprints no two
asses are identical and rear print can
automatically scan and identify any ass
ensuring only authorized users can
safely operate your toilet plus each adt
toilet system can store up to five
unique gas prints so your entire family
can enjoy total toilet access hello
steven's ass
finally our safety shield
using hundreds of tiny motion detection
lasers we create a virtual no drop zone
any solid matter greater in mass and
density than a fun size snickers bar
will automatically trigger a 120 decibel
alarm system
and alert our 24-hour monitoring center
where operators will dispatch armed
national guardsmen to your home
i'm sorry i'm sorry i just make a poopy
order now for a free upgrade to adt
toilet select and get round-the-clock
arm surveillance for your home toilet
with random bolt checks
plus a set of sink guard sensors to
protect you from the unthinkable
for true emergencies try our last line
of defense a remote detonation trigger
order adt toilet security now we're
number one against unwanted number twos
[Applause]